okay I am literally getting ready for my day and I put on some fucking music
I'm listening to Cardi B
that fucking song
that bitch can never be me like
that bitch can never be me like okay
and the fuck cause sometimes I listen to the music and like
the words don't sink in for a while as I'm listening to it
and she's still lying where she says
you're texting his phone while his face in my coochie
if that doesn't make you wake up and leave
like that's why your man's not answering you
because his face is in another girl's coochie
and you're gonna be crying over him
you're gonna be having his children
you're gonna be like this faithful little princess
or worse you're gonna be sinking to that level
and getting grimy with other people you don't even wanna be getting grimy with
because you're just trying to have somebody else's face in your coochie
just to get back at him
but that's not getting back at him
that's just lowering yourself
that bitch could never be me
no no no